einen wunderschönen vormittag meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren mein name ist
alfons haider und ich freue mich sehr
dass sie heute hier durch diesen festakt
begleiten darf würde ich jetzt
protokollarisch alle die 52
persönlichkeiten begrüßen
wissen sie was das bedeutet dann wären
sie nicht hassen es erlauben sie mir
dass ich das protokoll breche wir fahren
heute nicht nur 100 jahre österreich in
unserer heimat sondern wir feiern auch
für viele menschen einen genauso
wichtigen tag nämlich den muttertag
deshalb erlauben sie mir wenn ich
stellvertretend für alle mütter meine
mutter als erster begrüße ich bin froh
dass du es geschafft hast alles gute
liebe mama alles gute auch allen müttern
stellvertretend aber für alle
persönlichkeiten des öffentlichen lebens
meine damen und herren ist es eine große
ehre und freude team begrüßen zu dürfen
der eigentlich schuld daran ist dass wir
hier wunderbar sitzen mittlerweile
sitzen 500.000 stehen schon
das haben die veranstalter auf so
angenommen schön dass sie da sind herr
bundespräsident außer dienst dr heinz
fischer
wir begrüßen eine gästen und gäste aus
wien wir begrüßen alle österreicherinnen
und österreicher ladies and gentlemen
firmen wollten wir ein bisschen auf der
firma präsident auf der regatta von
costa tochter ins fischer wir
celebrating zu der handelskosten history
of truth is everything von at&t war dies
die einzige dame über feste haben
da haben sie bieten aufzustehen meine
damen und herren eine dame und fast 100
die zeit von 1918 1938 war geprägt vom
niedergang der donau monarchie
am ende des ersten großen menschen
vernichtenden krieges mit bis dato
unvorstellbarer grausamkeit mit der
abdankung kaiser kam es endete die
monarchie und österreich wo die republik
die erste republik bis 1934 der
austrofaschismus und ab 19 38 der
anschluss an das deutsche reich
zerstörten die ersten gehversuche einer
jungen republik musikalisch hören wir
jetzt und der rest ist österreich von
florian 19 trommel und trompetenklänge
versetzen uns in eine kriegssituation
medien melodien fragmente heidens
kaiserhymne erinnern an die habsburger
zeit machen aber dann mit einem viertakt
der aufbruchstimmung platz über einem
monat beginnen die friedensgespräche
sammer und ein letztes mal ertönt an
heidens kaiserhymne ein letzter
verzweifelter versuch das
österreichische reich zu retten
auch die akzente symbolisieren den
endgültigen untergang fand ex
ministerpräsident sprach sagte der rest
sind riesch der rest ist österreich
höher als jetzt zwei musikstücke rest
ist österreicher und verloren heute und
es in tanjong adventure von thomas doss
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das war meine damen klaren als ein
kleiner makel von thomas doss das stück
vorn aber eine welturaufführung meine
damen und herren und wurde von einem
jungen österreicher kontrolliert immer
große welt karriere voraus sagt nämlich
thomas 19
für mich ist es das erste mal dass sich
personen fest hat einen lebenden
komponisten treffe sie sind gut möchte
ich ihm herzlich begrüßen
der junge mann der erst drei ist der
kompromiss thomas tors ist der komponist
thomas 19 applaus er hat heute er diesen
wunderbaren musikalischen gerüst
österreich populär was hat sie bewogen
das zu machen
ja es gab einen kompositionswettbewerb
vom österreichischen blasmusikverband
und dieser wettbewerb hat er zum thema
100 jahre wirklich österreich und hier
wollte ich eben diese geburtsstunde auch
zum thema nehmen
das geht eben um die entstehung der
ersten republik und ist du hast das kurz
vorgestellt vielleicht auch noch zum
schluss ich habe auch versucht am
schluss noch eine ganz einfache melodie
zu schreiben weil es ja auch darum gibt
dass dieser kremers angesagt
der rest ist als österreich und ich
wollte eine einfache melodie schreiben
die die sich dann weiterentwickelt so
etwas sehr schönen das lied ich als
schön empfunden wird bleibt jedem selbst
überlassen
aber ich wollte einfach eine schöne
melodie für dieses schöne herrliche
landschaft dargestellt meine damen und
herren thomas heute heute ich habe die
große hat heute die generaldirektoren
wissenschaftlichen chef zu hören von
stella rollig zu mir die bühne zu bitten
eine damen und herren stella rollig mehr
oder weniger die hausherren hier bei uns
heute applaus bitte
ehemalige bundespräsident ist da viele
persönlichkeiten des 20
der sohn die natürlich auch geschichte
wäre sie unter dem fall mann stehen
bewundere an der fortbildung durch
bietet die herren hier auf der bühne ich
hoffe sie war keinen sonnenstich
bekommen und zwar stunde so sitzen bitte
tun sie irgendetwas auf den kopf meine
damen und herren was immer sie mit haben
damit nichts passiert jährige frau in an
einem geschichtsträchtigen platz wie dem
hier so ein fest veranstalten warum hier
im schlosspark warum heute zunächst sie
haben mich freundlicherweise es
hausherren angekündigt es ist eine große
freude selber einmal grüß gott und
willkommen zu sagen auch im namen von
wolfgang bergmann den wirtschaftlichen
geschäftsführer
warum heute dieses konzert dem wendet er
das spendet er war seit gestern 300
jahre immer wieder und bis heute ein
schauplatz und oft auch ein schlüssel
ort europäischer geschichte und dieses
konzert heute steht es um marsch als
hoffnung für ein gemeinsames
demokratisches europa den wir uns hier
im belvedere verpflichtet fühlen
und ganz im besonderen gedenken auf der
unterzeichnung des staatsvertrages dem
schlüsselmoment in der geschichte der
zweiten republik fünfzehnter 1955 diese
unterzeichnung hat hier im marmorsaal
des oberen belvedere stattgefunden
und man kann sie heute auch um das ist
ganz toll denn die landeshauptfrau
niederösterreich hat ihnen übergeben für
ein paar tage heute hier sehen ganz
genau sie sehen heute hier das einzige
vollständige faksimile des
österreichischen staatsvertrages dank an
johanna
dieses ist im besitz des landes
niederösterreich und heute nur heute
hier im marmorsaal wo wir auch die
original situation der unterzeichnung
wiederhaben auferstehen lassen und das
ist für jede frau und jeder mann frei zu
gehen ist meine damen und herren lernt
man die aus dem stets sein hier
dieses bildet er hat ja mehrere
identitäten nimmt der historischen
bedeutung ist es auch aufgrund arten
tektur ein tourismusmagnet es ist eine
bedingung einer der wichtigsten
kunstmuseen wie passen diese pole
zusammen verriet wir sind in aller
erster linie dem ursprungsgedanken das
kind wird er als museum verpflichtet das
belvedere war das erste öffentliche
museum österreichs das war noch die
gründungsidee maria theresias man stelle
sich vor das war damals wirklich
revolutionär im achtzehnten jahrhundert
und unser auftrag ist so viele menschen
wie möglich die kunstschätze hier nahe
zu bringen
wir haben im märz dieses jahres die
sammlung ganz neu aufgestellt
und wenn sie durchgehend hoffen wir dass
das gelingt was unser antrieb war
zusammenhänge gut verständlich zu machen
und diese wunderbaren kunstwerke nicht
zuletzt der kuss von creme durch
pointierte texte zu vermitteln so dass
wirklich jeder und jede etwas hier
mitnehmen kann
sie sind jetzt seit 16 monaten die mehr
oder weniger auf der hand auf
künstlerischem verantwortliche was war
denn das schönste erlebnis für sie bis
jetzt das schönste erlebnis war
zweifellos den kurs ganz aus der nähe
sehen zu können
wir haben ihn im zuge der neuaufstellung
zusammen
von einem raum in den anderen gebracht
das ist man kann sozusagen ein haupt-
und staatsakt und das war einer der ganz
seltenen fälle überhaupt wo der kurs von
seiner glasvitrine befreit wird wo man
wirklich also auf millimeter an die
malerei herankommt und das ist sicher
unvergesslich der nächste coup folgen
hat das ganz einfach
sie ist eine dieser hand kurz danke
schön meine damen und herren stella
rollig die generaldirektorin hier
wir kommen jetzt einen zweiten block die
zeit 1938 bis 45 die wohl dunkelste zeit
europas übergreifend auf die ganze welt
zig millionen menschen finden den tod
durch krieg das vertreibungen verfolgung
bis hin zum versuch der auswertung eines
ganzen volkes
unfassbares leid gibt es zu ertragen ist
am 8 mai 1945 in europa heißt der krieg
ist aus aber im pazifik in japan dauert
es noch ein halbes jahr bis nach dem
einsatz der ersten furchtbaren atom welt
der krieg endlich endet musikalisch
zeigen wir in diesem blog und starten
mit erich korngold als junger
komponisten wie das wunderkind
bezeichnet musste nun wirklich 34
fliehen ging nach hollywood zwischen 35
und 46 schiebe die musik für 19 filme
und der hinz zwei oscars von ihm als
eine seiner bekannten stücke nämlich
dass sie vor und danach folgt der story
of anne frank von otto schwarz ihr
tagebuch ist wohl eines der bedeutensten
dokument dokumente dieser zeit denn es
vermag unserer jugend mehr zu vermitteln
als es fakten in einem geschichtsbuch
verläuft in einem amsterdamer hinterhaus
jahrelang versteckt 44 wird sie verraten
sie und die ganze familie werden
verhaftet
im märz 45 stirbt einen franc im
konzentrationslager bergen belsen
meine damen und herren in zeiten in
denen die existenz von
massenvernichtungswaffen angezweifelt
wird manchen und rassismus wieder im
vormarsch ist kann es glaube ich nie
genug werke zum gedenken geben jetzt für
sie das sichert von erich korngold
astoria verfahren von otto schwarz
[Applaus]
wie viele jungen herangeht ist sollen
unter solchen und gilt jetzt kommt an
und erwähnt zwar bis den ofen wirklich
wieder anlegen ersetzt verdienen schon
applaus bitte werde das ist natürlich
ist so ein symphonisches orchester nicht
wirklich einfach so lange es die
instrumente nicht weggeht ist alles in
ordnung
ich habe eine tochter anders aus wenn
sich alle nein das muss nicht viel
vergeben den nächsten zwei stücken
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja
[Musik]
[Applaus]
darunter war
[Musik]
o
allen voran frank meine damen und herren
die gabel die gerade musik des heeres
unter der musikalischen leitung von
heidrun taus ganz rasch geht es weiter
mit john williams video sieg zu ziehen
dass liste berühmter ein weltberühmter
stil von sieben spielberg oscar schien
verwettet über 1200 juden aus polen und
der tschechoslowakei das leben indem er
sie in den rüstungsbetrieben in seinen
beschäftigt und damit vor dem tod in
auschwitz bewahrt das zweite musikstück
kommt das einem vielen ja kaum mehr
während das war wirklich ehrlich und ihn
so erschütternd brutalen bildern gezeigt
hat der soldat james ryan ebenfalls von
großmeister steven spielberg daraus die
bearbeitete fassung von philips park hin
zu erfahrungen jetzt viel von childers
ist und dann hinzu der folgen von
philips
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ja
dankeschön jetzt kommt der teilen ganz
rasch meine damen und herren für sich so
mitglieder blockieren mitsingen
wir nehmen die wir alle kennen und das
symbolisiert die alliierten mächte der
krieg ist vorbei
unser land wird in vier zonen aufgeteilt
usa sind werte union frankreich und
großbritannien
aus den usa werden sie ein musikalisches
werk das sie im schlafe erkennen werden
nämlich stars and stripes forever unter
dem sternenbanner von john philip sousa
aus der ausdruck in die sowjetunion von
dizzy stratford er versucht mit dem
stück das most die nationalhymne der
sowjetunion ein bisschen und zu
modernisieren und damit die dort frei zu
zeigen wie frankreich haben wir es ganz
einfach da gibt es natürlich nur ein
konto was in der unterwelt und die
musikalischen block beschließt
großbritannien nicht kommen burgi von
canons auf ford könnte mir vorstellen
dass sie diese melodie erkennen werden
das könnte auch ohne weiters seien dass
sie vielleicht mit werken setzen sie
sich jetzt in diesem nächsten acht
minuten mit uns gemeinsam mit den großen
jeep christi stars and stripes rasmus
krank und kaputt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
einen riesenapplaus blicke das war's
okay wurde und deren der
österreichischen gerade musik des
österreichischen bundesheeres heute beim
fest österreich
jetzt kommt der block 13 45 55
die zeit nach dem krieg bis zum
staatsvertrag war geprägt von hunger und
dem streben nach unabhängigkeit und viel
wurde wie immer besonders den frauen
wieder auf vorab verlangt in einem
unfassbaren kraft genanntes unseren
großeltern und eltern dieses land wieder
blühen zu lassen zu dem zu machen was es
heute ist eines der schönsten den
sichersten ländern aber gott sei dank
gibt es in dieser zeit auf menschen auch
schon in den letzten jahrzehnten die
sich immer wieder zu wort melden oder
auch mahner
unser nächster gast der einzige der hat
eine rede halten wird ist eine theater
dieses festaktes und ist in all seinen
funktionen in seiner politischen schon
auch als mahner auf der ferse einer der
nicht den finger dazu gibt meine damen
und herren es ist eine große ehre den
oberbefehlshaber des österreichischen
bundesheers im bundespräsidenten außer
dienst dr heinz fischer auf der bühne zu
begrüßen
helga fischer
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau generaldirektorin als
unsere gastgeberin hier im wunderschönen
pd dr
herr präsident des obersten gerichtshofs
professor rats sehr geehrter herr oberst
stefan kirschner als chef der garten mit
der ich viele jahre gut
zusammengearbeitet habe und ihre
musikalischen qualitäten kennengelernt
haben meine sehr geehrten damen und
herren des jahres in 18 war ein
geschichtsträchtiges ja und hat den
hundertsten geburtstag in der republik
gebracht nicht den hundertsten
geburtstag von österreich österreich hat
eine geschichte ist erstmals urkundlich
erwähnt vor mehr als 1000 jahren und die
habsburger monarchie hat eine geschichte
von mehr 600 jahren aber die republik
österreich so wie es sie heute kennen
und schätzen wurde als resultat einer
schweren geburt 1918 gegründet
und dieses jahr in dem wir uns heute
befinden und also 100 jahre
zurückblicken hat auch andere wichtige
historische daten im märz 1938 weiß das
so genannte anschluss an hitler zeit
lang im november 1938 waren es die
ersten ganz schweren organisierten
pogrome gegenüber der jüdischen
bevölkerung mit brennenden synagogen etc
3 in wien 19 48 etwas erfreuliches
nämlich die menschenrechts deklaration
1968 ein ereignis das man wahrscheinlich
als anfang vom ende der kommunistischen
diktaturen in europa bezeichnen kann
nämlich der prager frühling und wenn man
auf die geschichte zurückblickt dann
fragt man sich was ist eigentlich
geschichte
es ist die summe der ereignisse und
entwicklungen in bezug auf den menschen
die hinter uns liegt und die völlig
unverändert war es man kann das war das
was war nicht ändern
man kann vielleicht versuchen geschichte
zu fälschen
aber das ändert nichts an dem was war
die zukunft ist das was vor uns liegt
das was wir noch gestalten können wo wir
noch alle chancen haben etwas zu ändern
und der schnittpunkt zwischen geschichte
und zukunft ist die gegenwart und die
geschichte ist nicht nur ein lesebuch
über das was geschehen ist
die geschichte ist auch ein lehrbuch
wenn man daraus für die zukunft lernen
kann
das bestreiten markt oder sind ein
bisschen regen resignativ und jojo die
leute werden niveaus aus der geschichte
lernen oder die werden niedriger werden
aber das ist nicht einmal die halbe
nicht mein viertel wahrheit weil unsere
gegenwart und auch unsere zukunft ist
nicht vorstellbar ohne die geschichte
und ich ich könnte es beweisen und
andere haben es schon bewiesen dass die
zweite republik in falun die gründung
der zweiten republik und die umstände
unter denen durch zusammenarbeit die
zweite republik geschaffen wurde nicht
erkennbar werden ohne dass was ich
vorher abgespielt hat
das updaten der ersten republik in die
diktatur in den bürgerkrieg die
todesurteile an kurze zeit später der
mord an
dollfuß durch nationalsozialisten und
das hineinschlittern in die
hitlerdiktatur die von außen durch
militärische besatzung erzwungen wurde
aber viel ist auch im land selbst
vorbereitet worden und diese zweite
republik hat eben das wollte ich die
rede sein
habs auch gesagt aus der ersten republik
gelernt und es hat jede zusammenarbeit
jenen geister zusammenarbeit gegeben auf
den wir natürlich heute noch stolz sind
von dem auch noch elemente vorhanden
sind den wir uns jedenfalls sind
zentralen fragen unserer staatlichen
existenz bewahren sollen
und der letzten endes auch wesentlich
dazu beigetragen hat dass der
staatsvertrag möglich wurde
ich war bei kriegsende der ersten klasse
volksschule
natürlich kann man sich da noch an
vieles erinnern
und als die möglichkeit des abschlusses
eines staatsvertrages und damit der
befreiung von den vier besatzungsmächten
irgendwie realistischer geworden ist
bereichen der siebten klasse gymnasium
etwas mehr als ein jahr vor der matura
und damit kein missverständnis entsteht
der april 45 und 3 45
da ist eine riesige last von der
österreichischen bevölkerung abgefallen
die last eines mörderischen krieges die
last der diktatur hitlers die belastet
die laster besetzung durch nazi
deutschland
die last einer brutalen geheimen
staatspolizei gestapo die tausende
menschen exekutiert und hingerichtet hat
bis in die aller einer letzten tage der
nazi diktatur
da ist das wort befreiung absolut
gerechtfertigt und ich erinnere ich wie
mein vater zu meiner mutter kubrick hat
über diese veränderung trotz aller
trüber und aller schäden und aller
schwierigkeiten und es ist mit
österreich aufwärts gegangen aber ganz
einfach weil es auch nicht mit den
besatzungsarmee und die haben sich dinge
geleistet und ich will gar nicht eine
besonders heraus greifen obwohl
diejenigen hier unter sowjetische
besatzungsmacht gelebt haben
wahrscheinlich am schwersten hatten das
recht und gesetz verletzt wurden das ist
eine ökonomische belastung war eine
psychologische belastung
und dann nach mehreren hundert
erfolglosen treffen von außenminister
oder vize-außenminister ist im april 55
1955 aus moskau die einladung gekommen
eine österreichische delegation sollen
nach moskau fahren um über den
staatsvertrag zu verhandeln kreisky hat
oft erzählt wie man in der regierung
damals versucht hat sich einen reim zu
machen
das essen das was wollen ist das nur ein
manöver ist das eine falle ist das eine
ernste absicht wie hochrangig soll die
russische delegation sein
und dann hat man gesagt nein stalin ist
gestorben vor zwei jahren damals märz
der machtkampf in der sowjetunion wurde
erst entschieden wäre hat der
gefürchteten kapitäns liquidiert worden
da ist eine neue führung in der
sowjetunion mit chruschtschow und
bulgarien und st micro jahn molotow war
noch dabei ist aber kurze zeit später
auch abserviert worden
da könnte eine chance liegen
und so ist die österreichische
delegation als bundeskanzler vizekanzler
außenminister und den staatssekretär
kreisky bisher proporz war da auch dabei
zusammen gesetzt worden und nach moskau
gefahren
und ich kann jetzt nicht berichten wie
das gelaufen ist aber es ist positiv
gelaufen und heute setzen
55 wo schon die delegationen der vier
alliierten in wien eingetroffen sind ist
noch an letzten details verhandelt
worden
bis morgen bis zum 14 und das sind noch
einige positive veränderungen zustande
gekommen
vor 15 uhr war ein sonntag
ich war ein politisch interessierter
gymnasiast ich habe mein fahrrad
genommen von hitzigen klein zur straße
und nicht nur er geplant zum ende der
und habe mir das angesehen und ich werde
das nie vergessen diesen dieses gefühl
diese diese dieses gemeinschaftsgefühl
dieser jubel
diese dieser versuch sich vorzustellen
was das überhaupt bedeutet dass dieses
die besatzungsmächte abziehen
dass der letzte am 25 oktober das land
verlassen haben muss bis 24 uhr und es
war noch die sowjetischen soldaten die
sich am längsten zeit gelassen haben und
die buchstäblich
ist zum interesse zumindest bis zum
letzten tag geblieben sind
und dann fädelt in seinem glück für den
staatsvertrag hergezeigt hat man muss ja
wissen dass viel geld der verdienstvolle
bundeskanzler
ab 1945 mehr oder weniger abgesetzt
wurde von seiner partei nach den
verbrechern und vor allen 19 53 und der
wahl bitterböse auch auf seinen ängsten
frank julius raab hat sich zurückgezogen
ins privatleben und raab hat ihm dann
das angebot gemacht außenminister zu
werden nach dem rücktritt des
außenministers krone und figl hat das
angebot angenommen und in seine amtszeit
ist der abschluss des staatsvertrags
gefallen also auch für ihn persönlich
ersteht der gewissen gewissermaßen für
die gesamte bevölkerung in seiner freude
in seinem jubel in seinem glück und wir
wissen welche schlüsselrolle der
staatsvertrag und dann die neutralität
gespielt haben und dass wir in der
zweiten republik so wie sie heute
dasteht
den schlüssel jahren 1945 und 1955 aber
natürlich auch 1995 beitritt zur
europäischen union verdampfen und daher
bin ich froh und dankbar dass
das mit diesen festtag es ist ja nicht
nur ein festakt gestaltet mit einem
wunderschönen programm mit der einladung
an die bevölkerung die kunstschätze des
bwt erkennen zu lassen vor general
direkt hat das sind wahrscheinlich viele
überstunden angefallen und viele die
ihren sonntag in den dienst dieser guten
sache stellen müssen ebenso wie beim
bundesheer
aber es ist ein siebtel und waren mit
einem fast zu schönen wetter und mit
einem kurzen programm
und ich danke für die durchführung
dieser veranstaltung und natürlich auch
für ihre hoffnung sagte es lebe unsere
republik österreich
meine damen und herren jeweils ein
frischer rede ist haben dieses feature
vor was hörst du dann auf dem weg dahin
es war wunderschön wer weiß nicht wessen
gänse abbekommen der bundespräsident
entschuldigen sie sich vorstellt 55
fährt ein junge der politisch
interessiert ist mit dem fahrrad der
herren steht auf der anderen seite und
hörte setzte bei der zeit später sitzt
er hier als er wollte der
bundespräsident das kind wie ein märchen
herr dr fischer möglich sie lange auch
als politisches politisches gewissen
gerade jetzt in der republik österreich
bei uns bleiben
nachdem es kein offizieller start ist
aber wir trotzdem gerne die pompöse
spielen biete ich ihnen jetzt zeit
hundes mindern an meine damen und herren
nämlich die zwei geheimen probe sondern
einer geschrieben von johann strauß sohn
und eine geschrieben von franz von suppé
was war das schönste also einen tag zu
beenden
der schöne blau- oder und o du mein
österreich bitte bleib sind aber es gibt
noch eine überraschung
bitte strafpunkt super
[Applaus]
[Musik]
oh du mein österreich bitte eine riester
applaus den muss sicherlich noch rosig
und der garde kapellmeister hans haus
für dieses wunderbare konzerte nach
österreich wie getrennt sitzen denn
innovation stations danke schön herr
ostdeutschlands war dass das heißeste
konzerte siemens dirigiert haben das war
mit abstand das heißt es die konzerte
meine liebe damen meine herren im
technik ist groß ich gedanklich
persönliche bedanke mich bei den
österreichischen bundesgärten einen baum
an der seite wer das schafft offenbar
den kopf herzlichen dank wirklich
dankeschön auf dem zukunft österreichs
danke alle die heute uns unterstützt
haben dann durch den mitarbeiterinnen
und mitarbeitern des belvedere meine
damen und herren
der tag der offenen tür heute ist diese
21 uhr das untere belvedere das obere
belvedere 21 und das feld wieder 21
schließt um 18 uhr
es gibt zeitzeugen gespräche führungen
bitte werfen sie auch einen blick auf
die faksimile des staatsvertrages das
große programm endet dann am abend um 20
uhr im garten auf der südseite mit dem
großen zapfenstreich der tat und musik
unter der leitung von militärmusik
geschäft und ersten gerade gewässer
oberst magister bernhard her und jetzt
beenden wir musikalisch ist es unter
barren fest mit einem marsch der extra
für diesen anlass komponiert wurde
55 von josef vorteil
stellen sie sich vom 15 05 55 sieht auf
der anderen seite dieses schlosses die
magischen worte gefallen und der jubel
war nicht ändern wollen
meine damen und herren wir sollten nie
vergessen alles in unserer macht
stehende zu unternehmen
gegen innere wie äußere feinde dieses
geschenk jeweils zu verlieren
österreich ist teil
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das war die gardemusik ist es her ist
aber diese jungen haben hier ist der
siebenjährige summer and peter dem
großen applaus für den samuel das
sechsjähriges arbeite sitzen so der
phase etwas noch gibt samel und du hast
etwas jetzt mitgebracht was hast du dir
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sagen das kannst du mir schon denken
ich wünschte glück und fröhlich so gut
ich kann
[Musik]
das ist bei diesen anleihen tage ich hab
ich das ganze ja das wollte ich mir
sagen
der sechsjährige samuel mit einem
muttertags gewicht dass alle mit kann
meine damen und herren wissen carport im
schluss ich habe sie mir vorher nicht
gekannt ich bin dahin gegangen braucht
oder sich hinsetzen gesagt ich habe
gedicht
es ist mir dann interessiert immer um
angst um meinen job sammeln was wirst du
weil wir haben hier so groß ist
[Musik]
beantworten sie ist ja wunderbar twist
seine schöne ohne verein haben gott
meine damen und herren erlauben sie mir
eine persönliche satz 500 millionen
mütter sagt die uno
wir hatten heute nicht wissen weltweit
und jp morgan legen wird
500 millionen das können wir von dir
nicht verändern aber es liegt an uns
wenn es ihnen heute gefallen hat meine
damen und herren wenn sie es aufstände
kind haben die spendenboxen für die
aktion mutter und kind häuser ich
schnorre gerne in diesem fall das läuft
nicht bei einem festakt aber wir haben
uns gedacht wir machen oder noch
einfacher wenn sie die umgebung eine
frau kennen
die gruppe ist niemanden hat alleine ist
gehen sie einfach hinüber auch was der
trans service sie werden sehen
sie fühlt sich viel besser diese frau
auf wir leben in einem schönen land
wahrnehmen einem land das nicht nur von
musik und von seiten menschen bestimmte
zonen ab vom essen
deshalb freut mich ganz besonders dass
ich ihnen jetzt an findet darf das da
drüben die cola stelle des bundesheeres
steht es gibt ein fantastisches cola
sowohl auf der sicherheit für alle und
wasser von vöslauer bei dr fischer meine
sehr geehrten damen und herren
lieber herr oberstleutnant meine damen
meine herren von der gabe musikhalle
heute hier verantwortlichen das war's
das war ein fest österreich auf
initiative von herrn dr fischer ich
glaube es war wunderschön muss ehrlich
sein ungefähr 1000 menschen auch
geblieben die vaterrolle überraschen uns
jetzt alle der swimmingpool dorthin ist
für alle geöffnet
aufhören währende mit dem
radetzky-marsch bleiben sie gesund und
denken sie an österreich und ihre mütter
danke sagen bitte er oberster
[Applaus]
[Musik]
in diesem österreichischen zukunft wie
solche schilder mit dem sammeln von
unter 100 nichts mehr passieren das
war's dankeschön der die musik des
bundes bereits sie waren ein tolles
punkt mich und meine damen und herren
auf widerstand haben sie noch einen
schönen tag und genießen sie bitte hier
das obere dass unser petitum das
belvedere 21 bleibst du da kein foto
[Applaus]